this is going to sound pretty simple but
adding value gets you rich and when you
can continuously serve and add value and
help people and bring things to people
that they can use you'll get paid for
that because the money is just a
byproduct and energetic Exchange in life
you don't get what you want you get what
you're committed to so negotiate the
price in advance if you're going to do a
show break it down how consistent is
this show going to be is it gonna be
once a week is it gonna be a couple
times a week to be bi-weekly you're
showing up if you're in Dubai whatever
the case may be if it's Father's Day you
carve out 10 minutes whatever the case
will be because consistency is the g
code and then also like give yourself
permission to be less than perfect when
I first started the podcast I don't even
think I had a laptop it was in the
middle of the pandemic and I was
operating for my iPhone but I was doing
the best I can with what I had at the
time and I didn't let anything derail me
I just started going and you figure
things out along the way
all right believe Nation I have a very
special guest for you today Mr Craig
Siegel uh you guys have known I've been
talking about the concept of the biz Dev
show where when you're first getting
started the content game instead of
having to go and go direct to camera and
memorize a script you could also do a
show where you invite people on to be a
guest and hopefully this also leads to
revenue for you sales few opportunities
connections for you and that's the biz
Dev show and one of the guys who I see
being most consistent at this with
hundreds and hundreds of episodes under
his belt now is Mr Craig Siegel welcome
aboard man first of all thank you so
much for having me you know how much I
love you every time we get together it's
magic there's no place in the world I'd
rather be them right here with you let's
have some fun let's get nuts I love it
so you've got just for my audience
you've got the CLS experience you've got
a paradigm shift uh how many episodes
have you done the power of ship we've
done 128 weeks consecutively no weeks
off Christmas New Year's holidays all
the things things Dave Meltzer and I
traveling different places and then the
podcast the solo one that we had the
sales experience I'm not 100 sure but
over 200. so why and how did you start
the show of interviewing other people
when I started CLS and I reinvented
myself I looked at it as like a 10-lane
highway with each lien consisting of
something different for the brand
speaking Community coaching the podcast
shows all the things and the reason why
the shows were so important for me were
for a couple reasons there's so many
different things that they hit number
one I think it's a great vessel to
create strategic relationships with
other people that you might not have the
means to collaborate with right because
let's just say you're looking for
someone out there that's doing some
great things they're busy you're busy
but all of a sudden you have this
podcast where you guys can meet and have
a conversation and you can interview
them so that's obviously great and then
also when you interview people one thing
I take great pride in Evan is building
unbelievable Rapport and what I mean by
that is do doing the homework
preparation breeds confidence focusing
understanding who they are not asking
the same cookie cutter generic questions
and when you're able to build a really
thick Rapport and really cultivate that
deep meaningful connection and
relationship there's a good chance that
the guest is going to want to share that
episode and then you have the
opportunity to infiltrate their
audiences and their communities people
that might not have been familiar with
you and then that always leads to great
things business and so forth I mean what
I love about the business app show is
you know there's people who you might
want to know and connect with but they
may not go to coffee with you
but they'll come on your show you're
like oh you have a podcast oh yeah I'll
spend half an hour with you let's grab a
virtual coffee and and talk about it
where it's so much harder to get them to
hang out with you in New York or
wherever you know it's just so much
easier to get them on so how did you get
your first guests for your show when you
were first starting this out back in the
beginning yeah so I was I was really
persistent and I felt really big like
for my podcast specifically I didn't
want to just have like normal civilians
and stuff like that I wanted to have
really big recognizable guests because
my thought process was that if I did a
really good job of the interviews they
would likely share the conversations and
then I'd have the opportunity to
infiltrate more people and and meet more
people and really extend the reach and
spread the impact and so when I first
started this I didn't have celebrity
friends and connection and stuff like
that so I didn't have anything to point
to but I was really persistent and I'm a
big believer in creating win wins right
like if you're gonna reach out to
Someone Like You that's super busy and
gets approached all the time why would
you stop and want to do my show well one
thing that I can offer you is we have a
really really loyal and engaged
community and just to be clear in my
opinion there's a big difference between
a community and an audience an audience
is like metrics and a lot of people have
fake followers let's call it what it is
but a community is personally it's a
human connection and when a guest is
going to be on our Shelf there's a very
good chance our community is going to
want to enter their orbit find out what
they have going on maybe do business
with them buy their book get involved
with their programs and so forth and so
that's one of the things I was able to
offer a lot of these guests and then
also the power of being persistent and
consistent and I know it sounds so
cliche but those are super powers that
are accessible for everybody and you
might not get a yes right out the gate
but if you stay persistent you keep
building your brand eventually it's only
a matter of time I really believe that
so what did you do like go back to early
early Craig I'm going to start this
podcast idea I'm gonna get some gas on
my show how did you make your list how
did you reach out to me you didn't have
a community yet to pull from what were
the yearly thoughts so I had a little
bit of a community before the podcast
but then ultimately like I would reach
out to one of the first guests that we
had on the show was one of our mutual
friends Dave Meltzer
um and I was just professional I was
energetic I was passionate and I was
really persistent and he respected that
and he said I'll do the show and then he
did do the show and we had a great
conversation he shared it and then also
now that I had Dave on who's very
credible and respected I was able to use
him as leverage to reach out to other
guests and and eventually I did more
stuff with Dave and I pitched him on
doing a weekly show the Paradigm Shift
we had Juwan you and I formed an
intimate relationship and then we
connected further and I had you on my
podcast and so forth so once you get one
use that as leverage you stay persistent
and you're able to get more but you have
to have something to offer so once you
do land someone because whoever's
listening to this right now and likes to
take action if you're persistent you'll
get somebody to say yes then you have to
do a really really good job and separate
yourself and don't ask the typical
questions like tell us how you got here
and stuff like that keep it refreshing I
love it and listen I think some guys are
energy guys
and some guys are numbers guys and and
some people will come on your show just
because they love your energy and like
Dave's an energy guy and I'm an energy
guy's like same I don't know let's talk
about this Craig guy he's got this
energy and vibe to him I'm gonna say yes
and I'll say no to like other much
bigger mainstream Media stuff and my
team gets upset at me all the time
Forbes like I don't care it's just it's
an energy Vibe flow thing and other
people are much more about the numbers
like oh like you're too small like
that's legit like some people say you're
too small or they ignore you and they
won't get back to you but it's focusing
on the people who just have that right
energy and they'll say hey yeah you know
you only need to get a couple like Dave
says yes to a lot of he does First Time
Shows he just loves serving and giving
back and it's just he loves helping more
than it's not the first time in his mind
like what's this going to do for me all
right Craig if I come on your show right
like he just wants a servant help and
then uh I mean another easy hack is you
look at who follows them on Instagram
like who's following Dave on Instagram
those are all people you can now reach
out to and say hey I had Dave on my show
do you want to come on my show that's a
strategy that we used but proximity and
fear of influence and circle of friends
and then like dominoes they start to
fall and then all of a sudden you stay
consistent and now you are the show that
they want to make a pit stop on when
they're promoting something so 100 I I
followed that exact same strategy myself
yeah and then if you have similar like
the people who follow I've been on the
show Dave's been on the show there's
people who follow both me and they
follow Dave you know in some circles
Dave Meltzer and Evan Carmichael means
nothing you know like who are those guys
and in some circuits like oh my God you
had those guys on your show and so you
know if you find people who are
following both of us like oh wow you had
those guys on you know they're more
likely to say yes to you as well so you
know obviously that you've got the show
but you've got a business as well so
what's the main thing that Craig is is
selling right now it's so interesting
because I was having a conversation with
this about somebody recently and like
well I reinvented myself and stepped
into this I didn't do this for the money
I I finally found myself and I realized
I've been obsessive personal development
for so long and a skill set of mine
everybody's got some is that I can
communicate pretty effectively and so I
was on to something and I started my CLS
brand the coaching all that stuff but
then I realized like three months in I'm
like wait a minute if I'm gonna do this
and go all in it also has to be a
thriving business as well because I was
leaving Wall Street which was many
things but one thing it was was
lucrative and I had to turn this into a
business and so what I realized is that
this is going to sound pretty simple but
adding value gets you rich and and when
you can continuously serve and add value
and help people and bring things to
people that they can use you'll get paid
for that because the money is just a
byproduct and energetic exchange so
right now something we're very excited
about is we just launched our first book
the reinvention formula super pumped
about that we just hit we'll shoot
General bestseller right now we're
really excited about building our
community thank you brother we're
building our community with the CLS
membership which enables me to serve
many people in one shot it's a monthly
subscription speaking all over I do
someone coaching too but that have to be
a little bit more selective with because
that requires a lot of attention and so
forth so masterminds but but I would say
the two things that come to mind right
now are the CLS membership which is the
community which I'm really passionate
about and speaking as well so have you
been able to use the biz Dev show to
lead to specific
revenue or sales opportunities for you
yeah so I'll give you perfect examples
right so two people two solid guests not
like huge celebrities anything like that
but they were on my podcast and we had
such meaningful deep conversations that
they both loved them so much they asked
my team if they can have the raw file to
the conversations and they ended up
repurposing their episodes this is two
people at a similar time ironically on
their own shows and they all had big
shows as well and so when they
repurposed the conversation obviously
the in the description is hey this was a
great conversation I had with Craig
Siegel on his show the CLS experience it
was so good I wanted to share with my
community and I'm speaking for them and
then a bunch of people in their
Community about 40 combined ended up
signing up for our community our
membership which we're talking dollars
and cents that probably led to about 30
grand and then a couple people in their
Community which have organizations hired
me to come in and speak and it was an
alignment and that was was another 30
grand so just like that just by
infiltrating other audiences but it all
starts with doing a really really good
job with the conversations in the
interviews and then if you play your
cards right they will share it and now
once you're in their Community more
people find out about you and they have
an opportunity to work with you in some
capacity whether it's hiring me to speak
or enter my community and so forth
that's awesome I mean you made 60k just
by having two guests on your Biz Dev
show it's it's amazing so I mean people
like to think dollars and cents but but
there's obviously a lot more to it as
well in the relationships and kind of
hard to quantify but are there any other
stories or things that come to mind of
the relationships you built and the the
brand and the value that it's helped you
create for your business from having
guests on your show absolutely I think
for me like I give you some examples
with dollars and cents but if I'm being
honest for me personally the most value
that I get from these strategic
relationships is quantitative right like
so for example all these people now are
in my network and my connections like
you and a lot of my closest friends now
and you know I don't like to ask for
favors too much but but as I just said
we launched our book and as I discovered
there's a lot that goes into a launch
right it's like a full-time job in
itself and you want to do a good job and
obviously bestseller best seller lists
aren't everything but do a thing do it
well you want to do the best that you
can and extend your reach and make the
biggest impact and so when we started
reaching out to a lot of the guests that
were on the CLS Experience Podcast is to
see if they'd be open to either having
me on their show or doing an Instagram
live to help promote the book and bring
awareness to their audiences pretty much
everybody said yes and to be honest you
I had a moment and I was journaling
about this and it was just the most
beautiful thing and what I discovered
from that is how rich you are it's not
necessarily your bank account it's the
meaningful relationships that you create
in because I I nurture these
relationships and I always like to
create win-wins and really go the extra
mile they all showed up for me and that
led to book sales and awareness and
bestseller lists which I'll have with me
for the rest of my career and so and
also just by like you know like by
association right like for example let's
say you wanted to work with somebody and
you see that so and so is connected to
all these really big influential High
achieving people there's a good sign
that that's going to be contagious you'd
be like oh if they all like that person
they must be pretty desire or they must
be doing something right so I mean it's
hard to measure that but that alone has
a ton of quantitative value just based
upon proximity so those things right
there huge quantitative value if
someone's watching this and they're like
okay I'm gonna I want to get started uh
obviously it's a lot of work you know it
wasn't just out of the gate babe secret
success you've been you've been doing
this as you said no weeks off or you
know years now uh I remember being on
one episode where it was you and Dave
and Dave was like in Dubai and it was
three in the morning or something and he
was exhausted he's like we're still
doing this because it's in the calendar
and commit to doing it so which is great
so if somebody is you know at the
beginning here like okay they're
inspired like I love what Craig's doing
I want to go start my own show what kind
of advice would you have for them
whether it's booking guests interviewing
guests staying committed what what
guidance would you give them first and
foremost
in life you don't get what you want you
get what you're committed to so
negotiate the price in advance if you're
going to do a show break it down how
consistent is this show going to be is
it going to be once a week is it gonna
be a couple times a week it's gonna be
bi-weekly once you decide that now
there's it's a non-negotiable you're
showing up if you're in Dubai whatever
the case may be if it's Father's Day you
carve out 10 minutes whatever the case
will be because consistency is the g
code and then also like give yourself
permission to be less than perfect when
I first started the podcast I don't even
think I had a laptop it was in the
middle of the pandemic and I was
operating for my iPhone but I was doing
the best I can with what I had at the
time and I didn't let anything derail me
or deject me I just started going and
you figure things out along the way and
and creating a successful show isn't
rocket science it comes with a decision
that this is what I'm gonna do and then
you nailed it staying consistent and in
regards to finding gas and so forth
number one you can absolutely do solo
episodes right because if you're
building a personal brand which
whoever's listening to this I I highly
suggest that you entertain that idea
especially 2023 but people like to get
an idea about you because you are the
vibe and a lot of our solo episodes do
bigger than some even the really big
guests and so if you're ever looking for
a guest don't let that derail you
sprinkle in a Solo episode but the the
real trick is to get a lot of guesses
you want to have a lot of episodes in
the queue right so for me like I work so
hard over a few months span that I don't
have to film another episode for another
probably till the end of the year and we
won't miss a week because we have so
many in the queue and someone listening
might be like well aren't some of those
episodes outdated well not really
because the conversations are so good
and so relevant so you always want to be
playing chess and reaching out to people
ahead of time so you never scrambling at
the last minute and then again negotiate
the prize in advance it's not easy but
it's simple if you're committed you'll
have a successful show so some of the
things I love look for because I get hit
up all the time to like can you come on
my show a lot of it happens over
Instagram where people are dming me I
don't know if you're doing that a lot
for finding gas but uh the first thing I
see is are they are they even following
me on Instagram
right so like that's a basic right it's
like hey man I love your show or I love
your content dot dot dot and then you
look at it they're not even following
how can they love myself right right so
okay that's an easy disqualification and
then I'm just looking for something
personal you know like just to your
point about doing the homework and doing
the research on your guests like is
there an actual reason why I'm coming on
your show or is it just a generic thing
that you're sending out to a million
different people right so I'm just
looking for some point I don't care how
big they are I don't care if I'm their
first guest or their 100th guest all
they care about is that we're gonna have
a good time and hopefully create some
good content and that comes from showing
that you actually care about this human
and so some meaningful if somebody said
hey I saw your story and I loved how you
know when you were a kid you went to go
see a child psychologist like that's
right on my home page right like that's
it's not like you even did a ton of work
but if there's something in there that
makes it personal it's like okay I like
I like this person I'm much more likely
to say yes and so just a couple of easy
things to to be able to get guests it's
shocking uh how many people will
actually give you a yes
when you think there's no way that that
person will say yes I agree 100 in fact
we have we're higher right now we're
growing we're scaling so we had that
luxury but just to be clear for the
audience I started as a solo act but now
we have the luxury that we're growing
rapidly and I have someone on my team
that's reaching out on our behalf to get
some cool fun strategic refreshing
guests and he said to me in a team
meeting last week I said I can't believe
all these people are just saying yes I
said we'll get used to it because he
obviously has something to point to now
and so forth but when he reaches out to
them one thing that I taught him is
don't reach out to anybody random like
actually go in there with a reason as to
why we want them and we think they'd be
a good fit and just to give you a kind
of reverse example I did a show last
week I've been I've been making my
rounds and doing the book tour and so
forth I haven't really done many like
one-offs and so forth but someone
reached out to me I think it was via DM
and they just got me like they
penetrated my soul a little bit and they
said something really meaningful it was
obvious that they read my book and
something stuck out them they do not
have a Big Show in terms of like
viewership and downloads but I said yes
because the person put in the effort and
I can tell that they did the legwork on
their own and so I said yes and so you
have to form that intimate connection
and even just hear you saying like
you'll be you'll be game or down to
support somebody if it feels like it's
an alignment and that's a lesson for
anybody listening right now
yeah and again like some people are
energy guys and that's what they that's
what they flow off of and so sometimes
when I'm a guest in somebody's show and
they're still at the beginning I'll ask
them on their show like how long were
you thinking of asking me before you
asked me
and it might be a month it might be six
months it might be a year as if you
asked me last year I would have said yes
just like I'm saying yes now right and
it's not to it's not to like to beat
them up and make them feel regret but
it's like hey like that next person
who's in your mind go ask them because
the worst thing is that nobody's gonna
say no I hate your face you know never
talk to me again the worst thing that
happens they just ignore you right or
they don't even see it but it's shocking
how many people will actually say yes if
you just do a little bit of homework and
and a little bit of customization and
personalization two lines that come to
mind real quick right there that I
always found funny and I'll say to them
like I'll say to my 101 clients that
want to do what I'm doing I'm coaching
them like a closed mouth doesn't get fed
and you can't lose what you don't have
so you got to take a swing you got to
take a shot I like it my version of that
is uh don't take the yes away for them
like you're saying you're saying no for
them you know they might say yes you
never know until you send a message 100
how do you think through now of like
booking guests and who to reach out to
and now you've got team kind of helping
you with this but how do you think
through who should come on as a guest
now Now versus you know three years ago
or when you were getting started yeah I
love this question look as we go through
different seasons we're into different
things different topics different
conversations so whoever I'm curious
about or I think that would add value to
my listeners because ultimately that's
what it's all about or even sometimes if
I'm being honest it's a strategic
relationship right I want so and so on
because I want to build a rapport with
them because I think there might be ways
we could support each other I know they
throw Events maybe I could be a speaker
or they speak about this and I think
talking about boundaries really hit home
so my audience based upon my last
Community calls so it really depends on
what I think is most relevant and
appropriate in the moment okay so let's
say somebody has a book that they want
to watch right yeah you just you're
going through this now so you got some
wisdom and expertise yeah say they want
to launch their book in a year you know
what how can I use a show to help me
start to build momentum for my book I
love the question so let's just say you
hypothetically are launching a book in a
year are you saying how how would you
use your own show yeah like imagine a
viewer like they're gonna launch a book
They're a thought leader they're not
they're not super well known but they're
launching the book they want to get it
out they want it they mean I hit list
but they want to start building momentum
for it and the book could be a course
the book could be like whatever thing is
if you're trying to you know ultimately
promote how can they use a Biz Dev show
to bring guests on once a week how
should they be thinking through you know
the kinds of guests that they want to
have ons that it's not only about
pitching the book in the course about
the relationship but like that's my next
thing that I want to get out to the
world and I want to clarify
relationships is is the most important
thing guys who have all the listeners
right now but if you were doing that I
would reverse engineer it and say okay
12 months from now I'm going to be one
to getting the word out there because I
really believe in this book and I want
to share with a bunch of different
audiences so what I want to do now is
start cultivating meaningful
relationships with people that might
want to share my book or have me on
their shows 10 months from now as we
build that launch team and so forth and
so start reaching out to guests that you
like to cross promote with now do a
really good job stay connected nurture
those relationships and then when it's
your turn you come back and say hey I'm
launching a book it's all about
reimaging if you think this might be in
alignment with your community I I love
to to do a swap or do a show or if
you're feeling cold maybe just hop on a
10 minute IG live and I could talk about
it on your platform and that all starts
with what you do today so I I would
literally reverse engineer and start
cultivating a list of dream guests or
people that you'd like to collaborate
with or possibly promote you know every
time I help somebody with their Channel
Elizabeth or whatever they always ask
hey how can I help you
you know like any time you give that
there's there's often this how can I
help you back and you're great at it and
Dave's great ad in asking just out of
the blue hey what are you working on can
I help you with anything
and and it's thinking about that
long-term relationship even if
somebody's been on your show like a year
ago and you're not you know there's
nothing that you're working on together
anymore just dropping a quick DM like
hey happy happy whatever happy labor day
Merry Christmas Happy New Year what are
you working on this year anything I can
help you with because it it forces the
reciprocity like people like man this
guy's legit never asked for anything
he's just trying to help and then in the
in the follow-up is like hey and what
can I do for you Craig he's like I don't
know I got my book out you know love
some love some exposure if you think
that's a fit but yeah I use that all the
time and what's funny is you think
everyone's heard it before because I'm
so used to saying how else can I support
you Evan and now sometimes like you come
across someone that isn't used to
someone saying that they're like oh my
God like a lot of times on the end of
the podcast before we hang up and I'll
keep recording I'll say with all the
exciting things you have going on right
now what's the best way for me in the
community to support you oh my thank you
so much for asking well now that you did
ask I haven't really announced this yet
but we have a course coming out or a
book or whatever the case may be and
then love it and it goes a long way and
then it goes back to again not being
salvation and creating those win-wins
and I use that all the time and and then
ultimately people do it back yeah and
listen when I thought about this show
right here I was like I want to create a
show talking about the biz Dev show uh
who do I want to have on
you were the guy who came the mind and I
just sent you a DM on Instagram and say
hey Craig
you want to come out of this just like a
couple days ago he's like hey how about
Tuesday and here we are recording just
because of not that we're in touch every
day and following each other and you
know super connected but just the the
little light touches every now and then
like it keeps Craig's name top of mind
it's like huh I wonder maybe we should
have Craig gone uh and so here we are we
got a few minutes left let's show me the
book
because yes
there it is yeah and we have a new cover
coming soon we'll say Wall Street
Journal bestseller which I'm pumped
about but yeah the Revenge of foil Lums
I'm super excited for it because you
know I haven't done everything right my
whole life not even close but one thing
I did do really well the last few years
is Pivot successfully reinvent myself
and I think this book is not Niche it's
for anybody that wants to continue
leveling up and remove limiting beliefs
and think and play bigger and and do
some big meaningful epic stuff with
their life unapologetically make a lot
of money so I'm just so excited that the
feedback has been so strong and and one
thing that I've been hearing a lot which
is funny because I didn't have a ghost
rider for this I worked with Wiley who's
a major publisher and I remember
submitting the manuscript and they came
back with very little edits just some
grammar stuff and I never tell my fiance
my brother because those are my closest
Circle and they're like oh it's probably
because it was so good there was nothing
to edit I'm like all right I'll go with
that you know but they were very hands
off and so the some of the feedback has
been like it's your voice probably that
you're speaking to me and although it
covers a lot of different concepts which
I believe are Timeless it's already very
easy and digestible read there's 41
chapters the very short uh people having
a lot of fun with it and having
breakthroughs so as you can tell I'm
super pumped about it I love it dude
that's great you know the thing that I
have the hardest time with books is when
the chapters are like 40 pages long and
the text is so tiny and small and you
like read four pages and like what did I
just read and you have to go read it
back again so I love that it's easy to
digest and I'll say the reason why I
kind of got that idea is because when I
met my fiance I'll never forget I mean
she had this book whenever we travel and
it was by Jordan Peterson I don't know
much about him but from what I
understand he's brilliant she's been on
the same page for two years and I keep
asking like what are you doing with that
thing she's like every time I read the
first chapter it feels like I read a
marathon it's very confusing and that
always stuck out with me and I I can
relate so I wanted to make it very
digestible and simple so I'm with you
with that I love it well Craig thank you
for taking your time today if people
want to follow you where are they going
with the show the book the coaching the
speaking where do you want people to go
I think all the above anywhere you buy
books the reinvention formula any way
you listen to podcasts a CLS experience
anywhere on social media accurate single
underscore CLS if you like free
inspirational text throughout the week
and you live in the US you can text me
at
917-634-3796 text word Evan so I know
you heard it here and interact I love to
engage there's a good chance that it'll
be me
I love it thank you man appreciate you
thank you brother love you to see my
one-on-one with Craig's podcast co-host
Dave Meltzer check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see see you
there